nouvel épisode d'envergure bienvenue à
tous vous connaissez le concept on a
choisi un joueur on va faire son footing
report on va étudier son jeu dans les
moindres détails
on a choisi un candidat très sérieux
pour la draft 2021 un homme qui sait
shooter c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
puisqu'il est tout simplement à 100
contre 1 % à 3 points cette saison et
41% en carrière à gonzaga c'est un
coéquipier de joël ayayi notre français
c'est corey keith perte qui sera le
centre de notre attention pour ce
podcast et pour cela pour le scouting
report nous avons ben nous avons alan
nous avons comme un salut messieurs
s'avérait que j'ai décidé de caler mon
sens un peu chiant maintien alors là
écoutez j'ai changé de zone géographique
donc c'est le son c'est pas ma faute de
toute façon je parlerai loin possible
la parole était aux experts et
évidemment l'expert de la zone
l'expert de la zone dans notre data team
c'est julien qui est avec nous ça lui
julien salut c'est notre notre tupac et
nous voilà est-ce qu est ce que tu es
wells taiji til you die de façon à ce
qu'on puisse vraiment bien faire la
comparaison jusqu'au bout avec tupac
écoute je vais mais surtout le bandana
quand je sens pour moi ce que tu fait
froid sortez matri toutes sortes et le
ski c'est parti en verdure et tous ceux
qu'on suivait cap
tu
alors on commence avec une présentation
du joueur est là de mieux que monsieur
punchline qui est un meilleur micro pois
ce soir romain leroy est ce que tu peux
me dire est ce que tu peux me dire qui
est correct ispr en quelques lignes
en quelques lignes
c'est un joueur qui vient du grand état
du washington qui est originaire de
seattle
c'est une un artilleur un artificier ce
que vous voulez c'est un spécialiste du
tir longue distance qui présente ma foi
des stades très intéressante puisque
c'est autour des 50% à 3 points cette
saison
capable de clairement de clairement
mettre le feu un jour y met dedans avec
une palette technique ma foi c'est assez
développé ce qui n'est pas unie
dimensionnelle uniquement sur deux spots
up il est capable de traquer les
sifflets de faire des choses dans
différentes dans différentes situations
que ce soit du tueur d sur des sur des
sorties d'écran sur deux sur deux pick
and roll un petit peu même s'il faut
vraiment comme sur les mains à mende à
ligne droite pour attaquer le cercle son
bagage technique est intéressant même
dans dans l'attaqué du ch je travaille
depuis mai il a il a comme on dire il a
quand même pas c'est pas un grand
amateur de contact voyez si on peut le
définir comme ça très intéressant dans
le jeu sans ballon mais le jeu de le jeu
de gonzaga s'y prête beaucoup il ya un
jeu de couper tout un travail à l'opposé
qui fait qu'ils trouvent ça repose sur
des coupés sur des tirs dans la peinture
grâce à sa force et non le défenseur de
l'année mais fait les efforts malgré
tout s'est alors dit un titre c'est un
joueur que tu aimes à l'année est ce que
tu peux me donner un peu le profil
physique le portrait physique de quoi
qu'ils participent on a eu le profil de
technique
ouais c'est un
c'est un ailier quoi c'est un ailier a
fait plus de 2 m il a pris un peu de
poids et c'est un peu musclée par
rapport aux merkel quand on le voyait
avec y avait un chien mourra clark et où
il était déjà titulaire avec gonzague a
et il était un peu plus frais là il a
bien bossé ça se voit je crois il a
rentabilisé son sens confinement là
dessus mais oui là ce ne sera pas comme
naturellement sera pas un grand
défenseur mais il n'a pas des soucis
morphologiques ou physiques comme pour
vraiment se faire être une plaie ou
étant un joueur qui pourrait pas
défendre à une vieille il pourrait faire
le strict minimum des aides des choses
comme ça sans vraiment se faire
totalement cible est bon nous allons
commencer sa description on ira un peu
plus tard sur quel est son rôle dans le
collectif de gonzaga qui est la
meilleure équipe du pays classé numéro
un au moment où on parle évidemment les
aspects psychologiques les aspects un
petit peu secondaire de son jeu on
parlera de sa défense on parlera de son
jeu sans ballon mais d'abord le tir et
là j'aimerais j'aimerais avoir d'abord
julien là dessus les tirs au niveau du
tir qui est ce que tu peux me dire de
correcteurs à part les pourcentages
convoi il prend beaucoup de stands
kasyan foot quoi son son truc c'est le
catch and shoot il est très vite sur ses
appuis ça ça part très vite aussi il
déclenche très vite son shoot
et voilà donc sa grande foire se foutent
c'est de ces deux le 3.47 soude
substance est par contre sa part barre
en fait moi je trouve un bas sa part
devant le visage et ça finit pas
forcément très haut mais moi je trouve
qu'il va très vite
après romain c'est que romain sur les
les aspects on va dire et à la mécanique
non on va la mécanique je trouve qu'il
est bon c'est alors c'est stable s'est
équilibré sa part effectivement d'un
petit peu bas ça pourrait effectivement
finir un peu plus haut et j'ai envie de
dire attention elle arrive
on va on va pas non plus couper les
cheveux en quatre dans le sens où quand
on tire dedans 50% meurant moment on va
arrêter les exigences et je suis je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord sur l'analyse
technique stricto sensu mais je roule je
suis désolé je suis désolé pour
l'analyse mais mais derrière c'était ça
pourrait lever un petit peu plus il est
pas forcément toujours en extension
complète mais pour moi il ya une vraie
maîtrise et un joueur qui a experts du
tire donc il ya peut-être un petit
quelque chose à gratter là mais quand on
est déjà 50% à 3 points sur le volume de
tir qu'il a en dix matches où je jeté
des pierres 6,6 chipote de trop que dans
l'antique tentative par match ben est ce
que tu as vu des choses de haut niveau
de la production qui a pu parler à
lagnes par les parements de l'époque
pouvaient avec nous les brandon plat
compteur avec humour à est ce que tu as
vu une évolution de ses collègues pour
moi c'est carrick est ce parce que j'ai
vu comme une évolution s'est excusé ce
que j'ai vu comme révolution chez quick
me tuer comme beaucoup c'est sa capacité
à tirer dans différentes situations
julien parlait de de son équipe à un peu
bowie mais il est capable d'adapter
inapte à la situation moi je les ai vus
plusieurs fois elle capable de prendre
un dribble prendre un pas de côté et
puis cette façon il peut shooter en
sortie d'écran il peut shooter en catch
and shoot il n'est pas encore vraiment
capable de deux de créer son propre et
tire mais je ne crois pas
personnellement que ça importe parce
qu'on lui demandera jamais 193 % de ces
trois points viennent d'un catch and
shoot saison 85 l'année dernière 93 nuit
d'avant bref c'est beaucoup de catch and
shoot au niveau du volume mais alan ce
que disait bonne et intéressante sur les
types de tir différents qu'on va devoir
prendre au niveau du dessus il ya ce
côté je feinte
je fais le dribble de côté et j'arrive à
rester équilibré j'arrivais à faire tout
ça rapidement pour déclencher son tir
ouais complètement complètement
incapable de bien se rééquilibrer et
capable de aussi déclencher très vite
quand la passe et haute en effet ne
passe autant le corner direct sa part a
besoin d'eux des fois les gens qu'il
redescende le ballon doit avoir un geste
c'est hyper rapide y perdre c'est hyper
beau et c'est un garçon vous le répète
assez un expert du catch and shoot en
sortie d'écran il est pas mal et surtout
il est pas mal en sortie d'écran à une c
est parce qu il peut shooter de très
très long et comme tu peux jeter traite
comme si elle aligne un peu plus un peu
plus proche et que tu es qui est un peu
des écrans vers ligne à trois points les
défenseurs hausse pas sortir notamment
je les ai vus contre contenu virginia il
s'est mis derrière un mètre derrière et
essayez pas vraiment problème pour donc
ouais c'est vraiment c'est magnifique ce
qui passe qui propose aux tirs et
surtout c'est pas que cette année jours
il a 41 % en carrière en acier sur plus
de cinq cent dix tentatives donc c'est
un shooteur
ouais absolument romain simplement pour
expliquer il ya une question de jeu de
jambes aussi moi ce qui m'impressionne
beaucoup c'est sa capacité à peu importe
la course qu'il a fait avant se remettre
dans l'ombre dans ses propres appui est
arrivé pour déclencher très vite le tir
quoi ouais il est très bon pour se re
situer c'est à dire qu'il est ce que ce
que font les joueurs vraiment efficace
comme ça c'est qu'ils sont capables en
étant en étendant le mouvement ce 2 2 ce
qui est vrai de resituer très rapidement
et parfois même sans être forcément face
au cercle de au moins de savoir où il y
avait quoi c'est vraiment de leur compte
actualiser les choses faut être très
fort sur la coordination entre les entre
l'oeil l'oeil et la main pour ça pour ça
notamment
mais non une capacité à attirer d'à peu
près partout et de surtout de loin qui
est qui peut qui peut permettre de
compenser beaucoup de choses notamment
les aspects défensifs que moi je trouve
pas forcément scandaleux parce que bon
clairement c'est un joueur comme ça où
quand on s'intéresse à un joueur comme
ça surprend pour qu'ils défendent eux
vous fait on fait une connerie à mon
avis mais il est quand même capable de
faire le minimum syndical à mon sens
donc ça reste ça reste ça reste reste
pour moi ça reste un joueur un joueur
dont on tire un joueur de haut niveau je
laisse le seul questionnements que j'ai
à l'heure actuelle réellement il va être
sur la vitesse globale dire qu'ils
dégagent pas il dégage une impression d
équilibre de sérénité et de maîtrise et
de distance de tout ce que tu veux mais
dans les courses dont l'exécution
je ne vois pas là je vois pas la vitesse
je vois pas la vitesse je vois pas le
supprime une fois pas leur avis des
choses quand dire extrêmement difficile
tu as vu des choses difficiles mais t'as
pas vu des choses très j'ai vu des jours
difficiles à réaliser techniquement j'ai
vu des choses très bien exécuté
techniquement mais j'ai pas vu
l'explosivité la vitesse je cherche des
gens comme ça on pas le compare à des
gens qui sont pas son profil mais donnez
moi des noms de joueurs capables de
tirer des élites que je n'ai qu'à me
where he went après c'est l'extrême
évidemment voilà c'est ça mais duncan
robinson avait un peu cet aspect là
quand même un effectif où tu d'accord
avec moi là dessus mais cannes robin
gibb cet aspect on l'a pas trop vu
sprint et non plus il n'avait pas appris
il a beaucoup bossé avant de l'or du
temps de jeu à une bière
la partie iii l'évolution du rôle de
corée qui se porte et là je vais donner
la parole à julien qui est le
spécialiste de la conférence de gonzaga
ici parce que on parle de gonzaga
on parle entre autres personnes qui
connaissent cette équipe c'est une
écurie majeur de n 6 et maintenant
julien qui entourent corée kispert pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas du tout
vraiment line6 des volets qui tomberait
sur ce podcast pour se renseigner sur
qui se porte
voilà qui joue dans cette équipe quel
est le rôle de keith peart
qu'est ce qu'il ya autour d'eux sur le
sur l'équipe en face à cette année il à
traction arrière sont racontées doux et
toi comment on pouvait voir la jazz
angels
c'est sur le freshman qui éclabousse de
son talent en ce début d'année quoi n'a
pas dit mot
c'est de voir jouer c'est quand même
super bowl et d'une parce qu'ils
traînent là sur internet sur twitter là
où la vue est là le quarterback de
verlaine faible avec 1 n'a pas sa terre
mais attendra après un gars à yayi bien
sûr de français je vais layadi qui est
une super super début de saison quoi qui
montre qu'on n'est plus dans les tâches
sombres
voilà mes nombreux ce qui fait qu'il
fait pas mal de petits trucs aussi
pendant les matches qui a tout le monde
il de temps tout le monde mais il prend
sa part de lumière aussi c'est bien
cette année
moi j'aimerais bien qu'ils donc un peu
plus en contre attaque mais c'est un
autre sujet ce sera vous qui traitez et
puis il ya un an mme bartz est comme ça
qu'on dit mais mme bartz est pas comme
on dit benoît on est mardi noir qui
apporte aussi du peps là quand il rentre
c'est vraiment
ça aujourd'hui joueur un mois donc voilà
les bases arrières des créateurs c'est
un bon passeur c'est eux qui font toute
la création
et on parlait aussi la défense parce
qu'on va reparler tout à l'heure et en
fait ils ont beaucoup je pense par
rapport à l'année dernière comme
beaucoup des charges et qui se pare de
tout l'aspect d'un gros aspect défensif
parce que à yayi est seul en défense
comme premier rideau c'est infernal
quand il s'y met tous les deux ça
simplifie beaucoup le judo le rôle de
keith part qu'il est qu'il ya plus qu'a
fait rare des choses à faire il les fait
bien mais ça lui simplifie le boulot et
à l'intérieur il ya timmy c'est ça
diderot bogosta mixer montrer qui a été
montré un peu l'année dernière et que tu
as qui montre tout son talent quoi
lorgeoux ar post voilà c'est ça mais qui
peut aussi ce quarté pour poursuite à 3
et voilà il puis il est capable aussi de
sur des sons des petits moments de tenir
le ballon de près d ouverture il sait
faire l'epasa qui se porte aussi sur des
camps cool quand kiesler fait des
couples ils savent se retrouver tous les
deux mais c'est vraiment chouette à voir
donc voilà il est il est dans une qu'ils
partent ils évoluent dans une académie
de basket c'est sûr et par rapport à ce
que disait parce que 10e romain sur ses
déplacements par rapport à l'année
dernière je trouve qu'en fait il en fait
j'ai exagéré pour faire comprendre je
sais pas comment dire que cela mais
parfois ils se promènent quoi en fait il
connait tous ses déplacements ils savent
qu'on va tout il sait qu'on va le
trouver
donc en fait parfois mais j'ai
l'impression qu'ils se promènent quoi
vraiment il regarde même plus derrière
lui se promène il a dans son spot il
sait qu'il va compliquer pour moi lie
deux fils trouve le ballon et supra
c'est vraiment très calcaire turckheim
et voilà ouais ça c'est la conséquence
aussi d'une équipe qui domine quand même
d'une vague de saison sur ce salon dédié
c'est ça donc ça explique aussi
peut-être même si bon ils ont joué des
grosses équipes mais c'est juste qu'ils
payent peu tout le monde devant points
après sa victoire qui se dessine quand
même c'est pas tout de suite de blow
genre à dix minutes de la première mi
temps c'est fini quoi il s'est notamment
bien sûr mais donc contexte autre à toi
à moi tu es salam pour dîner pareil je
finis un juste là dessus tu m'a lancé le
ceto en over que ce parce que vous avez
vu ça a b c est parce que voilà que je
pense qu'aussi d'installer avec sexe qui
arrive et ça ça le décharge encore plus
de toute la partie création qui faisait
déjà pas beaucoup
et voilà quoi mais il est à plus de
passeurs espaces et lycées par rapport
au jeu de l'équipe il sait où vont aller
tout s'est vraiment hyper structuré
quand même là dessus peut-être juste à
un mot ben tu as tu nous disais avant le
podcast avoir regardé du gonzaga toute
la journée c'est quand même le genre de
contexte qui favorise la cote d'un
joueur le fait de jouer dans une équipe
comme ça qui fonctionne bien qui tourne
avec des arrières qui sont déjà les suns
c'est peut-être parce que probablement
un top 7 8 de la draft et il ya des
matches où on y prend que 5 6 shoots
quoi oui absolument mais il va appeler
joie comme quand vous appelez un style
d'équipé qui va qui va être kim avoir
les mêmes dispositions c'est à dire
qu'il remporte besoin d'un joueur pour
rapporter la lpo pour initier la taxe
n'aura besoin des joueurs pour finir
qu'il aura besoin de pièces comblement
donc j'ai beau ce ton en tête pour quick
espère qu il va se ramasser dans une
équipe comme ça qui est déjà très
ordonnée qui a besoin d'un joueur qui
connaît qui connaît ses responsabilités
par car comme le dit si bien un julien
tantôt s'il connaissait ses
responsabilités tellement sur le bout
des doigts que c'en est presque
caricatural à alan sur le le contexte
est ce que toi tu aurais tendance du coi
relativiser les performances de keith
pupart non j'ai plus tendance à utiliser
celle de secondes mais c'est un autre
débat qu'on aura plus tard et ans mais
surkis pertinent parce que c'est c'est
un rôle plaire et ça c est ça l'est déjà
et ça le dessin ne sera pas c'est un
genre comme tu es 10 93% de ces tyrans
catch and shoot il prend la plus savante
% de ces tirs à trois points en carrière
donc c'est un spécialiste c'est déjà un
spécialiste ça sera un spécialiste je
pense qu'on aura une bear et ses toits
qu'il faisait remarquer un peu l'an
passé on voit comment les spécialistes
du tir ont tendance est très très haut
drafté ces dernières années je pense que
si glee s'il continue il va ya il va
finir très très haut et ewz il
al'avantage par contre hui de voir
gonzague a je pense qu'il ya une dépêche
que plus rapide du pays
il ya très très peu de jeux placebo
transition ça pousse vite la balle après
le voilà après le ballon il ya du space
singh il ya des intérieurs qui tire ça
s'est posé des écrans
donc ouais c'est un contexte très
favorable mais pour lui c'est c'est
peut-être ce qui retrouvera aussi les
tâches pour peut-être mais ça booste à
un peu effectivement si on regarde juste
les chiffres bruts ce qu'il faut pas
faire complètement mais ça booste un peu
les chiffres bruts
romain tu nous parlais d'un joueur qui
vient de seattle est ce que ta [ __ ] à
gratter du contexte familial autour de
corée qui espérons passer un peu à
l'aspect psychologique
non j'ai pas gratuit du contexte
familial gérard est un peu lisse et doux
il est doux il est passé je vous
retrouve ça tout à l'heure pour voir un
peu ce que j'aimerais savoir si les gens
qui sortent à l'église
on a en attendant que tu trouves bns que
toi je sais que tu qu'une spécialiste
pour regarder les interviews et et
autres moments médiatiques de des
différents prospects donc qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que tu peux nous dire de kiss
pertes
bah voilà comment ils s'expriment par
rapport aux médias et même comment il
est sur le terrain
quel quel type de joueur il est ce qu'il
est déjà dans son rôle de role player
j'ai déjà déjà là j'ai un peu de baghlan
familiale pour vous quand eric sprott
c'est quelqu'un qui vient d'une famille
très aisée
il n'ya pas d'une famille de basket aux
milliers de familles très aisées pour
vous donnerez un exemple ils viennent
d'une banlieue de seattle des demandes
et à ce qui est à cinq heures de route
de spokane gonzague a joué sa famille
vient le voir jouer en avion ils sont
ils sont aisés à ce point là donc il va
rester lettres ont une fille et il n'y
avait pas besoin d'aller chercher un
scénario quoi est exactement mais c'est
vraiment un détail très important parce
que lui et sa soeur sont deux athlètes
si une soeur jumelle qui s'appelle qui
est ici qui qui est joueuse de
volleyball à seattle pacific university
où leur paternel travail et s'ils sont
ils ont été formés et ses deux enfants
là avec une éthique de travail
absolument incroyable
ça fait en sorte qu'ils ont été capables
que les clés que les parents ont été
capables de leur donner toutes les
chances de réussir et et les bleus en
ont visiblement profité ce que détaille
tu m'a marqué en entrevue avec un
briquet sporting expliqué qu'il est
demeuré à gonzaga au lieu d'aller à la
draft parce que il ça irait pouvoir
prendre un plus grand rôle donc
travailler plus d'aspects de son jeu
pour voir pouvoir devenir un joueur plus
complet ce décision qui est vraiment
très mature il ya bien sûr il ya pas
besoin d'argent donc il y avait le luxe
pour pouvoir prendre cette cette
décision là mais c'est quand même c'est
quand même quelque chose qui des moines
y témoigne d'une très grande discipline
mentale
on a aussi un autre détail aussi qui est
très important c'est qu'il regrette jury
l'année dernière donc une partie de ses
exploits cette année peuvent s'expliquer
par le fait qu'ils travaillent toute la
journée qu'ils bossent
dans le deuxième où il bosse beaucoup à
la salle toute la journée
exact auriez plus il ya plus de co donc
il peut se concentrer à 100% sur le
basket ball
donc ce qui ce qui fait apparaître cette
décision lot d'alerté un an et please
come back il est parti ça veut dire que
quoi il a un en avant sur le cursus
universitaire en trois ans en fait tout
dépendra son voisin s'est vite tu peux
graduée en trois ans d'accord avec
laquelle il a cadré ses îles et par gay
alors c'est un senior
mais c'est un jeune senior koné qui se
perd puisqu'il aura 22 ans l'année
prochaine a lieu comme prévu on n'est
sûr de rien au mois de ramadhan en plus
on sait pas encore bref juillet il aura
22 ans dans des trucs sur l'asie sera
sur son histoire
son grand père était voleurs
professionnels oui j'allais jallet main
si je te laisse finir on attend si tout
est en fait c'est d'un grand père qui
voulait qu'il soit footballeur c'est ça
tu as vu ça aussi
oui exactement oui dans le football
américain a joué pour les jets il ajoute
les jets à new york dans la nfl pendant
cinq ans donc c'est pas juste quelqu'un
qui a fait le camp d'entraînement ou
quoi que ce soit c'était vraiment ce
qu'est ce que je suis et j'ai gagné des
matches à l'époque j'en ai aucune idée
l'exploit d'en perdre romat a retrouvé
les référencements du lycée ou pas donc
en fait il ya pas grand nombre il ya bon
c'est improbable il ya un joueur qui
actuellement charleville mézières en
nationale 2 qui passe amène lycée mais
non il y a
il ya martell webster du même lycée à
new orleans
mais bon c'est la génération d'avant
c'était un peu le même profil quand même
ça ressemblait un peu
complètement je déteste pas la campagne
enfin que plus gros web après derrière
où il ya des glorieuses inconnu konon le
jouet une joueuse qui s'est perdu sur le
championnat néerlandais mais ya rien de
rien de très solides le fameux
championnat irlandais féminine les
autres aspects du jeu de corée qui se
perd on a parlé de son shoot pour être
un rôle player efficace en nba un
spécialiste du shoot on connaît duncan
robinson on connaît cameron johnson pour
te pour les citées dernièrement enfin
les dernières années plutôt à la 9e
on a besoin de quoi d'autre est ce que
correctifs porte là pour moi toute chose
on a besoin de pas casser le une le jeu
en attaque c'est à dire de pas faire des
mauvais choix
avoir un dribble vraiment trop
problématique faire des mauvaises
lectures pas faire la bonne passe jusque
quand il faut et on a besoin d'un
certain d'une certaine pour le jour pour
les ailes une certaine taille et un
poids minimal pour pas se faire ciblé
pas être banshee dans les confrontations
du club
c'est deux choses que je retiens et que
des joueurs comme robinson et harris ont
réussi à 11 alors qu'on aurait pu penser
que cette équipe est jeune harris joris
doit rice merci ami ben est ce que tu es
d'accord avec ça qu'est ce que tu peux
me dire de son dribble roman parlait de
effectivement beaucoup de lignes droites
j'ai noté pales de main gauche le cid
règlement gauche peut-être parce qu'on
lui coupe la main droite sur le tire
aussi et drag queen gauche mais finie
mais à droite beaucoup
ouais il ya eu beaucoup de la droite en
transition il est capable de chiffres il
beaucoup plus à l'aise à dribbler est
ouest en transition mais sinon ouais
c'est je dois je dirais même que le dit
moins confortable avec le ballon dans
ses mains que simplement pour dribbler
sirpa un certain plus qu'une ligne
droite il va être beaucoup plus voyez
beaucoup plus il sera beaucoup moins
confortable que s'il a créé quelque
chose pour le même support c'est pas un
jour ce type de joueurs là c'est pas un
des landes brooks par exemple c'est pas
quelqu'un qui va créer quelque chose à
partir de son dribble c'est pas
quelqu'un qui va kilomètres de lesparre
c'est quelqu'un qui va utiliser le dream
que quid de la prise de décision puisque
allen parler de ça c'est tout ça c'est
prendre la décision au bon moment en
fait il ya des stats qui peuvent nous
donner un aperçu julien tu parlais de
ballons perdus tout à l'heure par
rapport aux fins le ratio façon passes
décisives ballons perdus c'est un
indicateur certains il ya 12 % de passes
décisives cette année 6 % de ballons
perdus seulement mais en carrière il n'a
pas été sur un ratio négatif quand même
julien sur ce que tu as vu sur les
matchs que tu as vu est ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui prend des décisions bien
premièrement rapidement deuxièmement d
appliquer quoi ils tex ou dans le sens
je sais ce que j'ai à faire et je sais
pas ce qu'est ce qu'il a à faire
moi j'ai l'impression que dépasse là
cette année je suis dépassée sur mais
très simple quoi il fait pas de ce repas
du texte il fait des choses toujours
dans
dans le sens du jeu c'est propre mais il
n'ya pas bleu prise de risque ouais pas
ça demain c'est oui oui c'est pas c'est
pas quelqu'un qui va réussir à créer
comme disait ben grâce à ça alan
défensivement
qu'est ce que tu lui trouve qu est ce
que tu trouves pas alors il va pas se
faire viser de mettre 1 99 kg c'est pas
forcément le profil convient sauf si
c'est assez lent sur les appuis
notamment au latéral comme en convenait
de ce côté là c'est un peu pour moi
c'est un peu le souci coup en défense se
déplacer latéralement termes
d'anticipation des lectures ça va bah
c'est un joueur qui aura fait jaune je
pense plus de 100 titularisation en n 6
est sûre ça l'expérience ça va mais sur
les joueurs plus petits
il s'est passé pas se mentir il n'a pas
non plus une envergure énorme pour eux
si jamais doit il va venir aux contres
ou potentiellement embêter un joueur sur
un genre qui voudraient accéder au
cercle et où il n'est pas très pas une
très grosse vitesse de pieds je trouve
pas pas très loin pas très bons
mouvements
pas très bon au mouvement proche du
ballon le monde du ballon ça va parce
que il a l'air d'un il a une bonne
appréhension défensive et aussi ils
jouent beaucoup la carotte
j'ai l'impression que ça c'est à
expression magnifique certes il joue
plutôt numéro 9 quoi c'est sa bague on
s'agace ça va tellement vite en contre
attaque que des fois il zone un peu
heureux terre il ya trois points et puis
il va pas du tout rebond défensif
et puis les c'est un genre que met
d'ailleurs il a un ratio de rebond très
faible par rapport à la taille ça peut
être ça peut être une explication
absolument robin tu es donc revenu on
avait perdu
j'ai plus de chandails plus de son
écoute j'ai trouvé un candidat au même
titre d'ailleurs que je vous partage à
l'heure actuelle à willy breaking bien
sûr
cet hymne redondance là ouais
effectivement effectivement roman est ce
que tu peux nous dire quelque chose sur
le côté justement prise de décision de
corée qui espère-t-on c'était plutôt
satisfaisant prise de décision qui sera
offensif et défensif
ouais je trouve je trouve que
globalement ce qui fait ce qui fait en
attaque est assez juste
bon quand elle a essayé cette capacité à
franchir qui est pas forcément toujours
très claire dans l'est dans les duels il
a décrit un peu de contacts c'est
difficile après il a une qualité d'appui
qui est plutôt pas mal donc je vide est
capable de lire les espaces correctement
se pose pas de questions m'ont tiré ses
choix tirs sont quand même rame en force
et où on a vraiment pas justifier une
défensivement je rejoins ce que dit alan
c'est pas c'est pas si elle plus rapide
après je trouve qui fait les efforts
malgré tout mais bon le lien si si si si
grand père et était footballeur us
comprend un peu plus de chaussures sont
sur son format physique parce qu'il est
quand même assez à ses dents se
trouverait puis pendant au moins un mois
pour moi pour moi le meilleur indicateur
chiffré pour la prise de décision c'est
le nombre de balles perdues
alors certes il fait pas forcément des
as de passe mais bon y perdre moins de
ballons par match
il est une rentabilité sur sur le tir il
a 75 % de 50% à 3 87% lente et aux
lancers dont jetez plus la coupe est
pleine quoi on sait le produit pour moi
le produit fini et aboutit à l'heure
actuelle la question après sébacées
l'obs haye
c'est la transposition dans le jeu
dangereux et de billets qui va aller
plus vite ou il y aura inévitablement
des gens beaucoup plus athlétique et
beaucoup plus agressif une pression
défensive également qui sera différente
parce qu il sera ciblé comme spécialiste
qui sera ciblée après ce que ça peut
aller est ce que ça peut se projeter ses
plus grands qu'un dj reddick ou des
profils comme ça elle admet daniel
robinson
voilà c'est ça c'est plus grand et un
peu moins rapide que les désirs alix et
pato fameux profil mais je pense que son
son gabarit fait que ça peut ça te va
peut-être se transposer on va dire ouais
bah quoi si shoot avec le même
pourcentage évidemment évidemment que ça
va ça peut se transposer il fait le
gabarit de chalk river
il ya de quelques heures était à 2 1 96
kg là on est sur du 2 m 111 kg donc l'un
dans l'autre
bon pas non plus comparer ce qui n'est
pas comparable mais ce n'est pas la même
vitesse d'exécution non par contre
quelques revers va beaucoup plus vite
son tir est plus haut et c'est plus
rapide dans l'exécution mais il ya un
espèce de début de ressemblance
capillaire puisque qui se perdent s'est
laissé pousser les cheveux il joue avec
un le projet capillaire moi je préfère
celui de time un personnel en termes de
projets capillaires et le combo bondo
moustache est quand même beaucoup plus
cher beaucoup plus correspond beaucoup
plus chaud côté un peu grant west la
mairie coq un peu hippie autour de
hewlett à washington c'est lors de
l'attaqué penche sur ce à quoi
ouais c'est ses limites on est limite
dans mon gynéco d'oublier le titre la
ctu écumé o'flynn tropiques je pense
qu'il peut jouer band un dernier mot sur
les capacités techniques et un mental de
corée qui se perd tu l'as peut parler de
son jeu sans ballon
moi je trouve j'en ai parlé thual a
mentionné pardon c'est effectivement ce
que tu peux rentrer dans le détail des
ben ouais c'est un choix forcément sur
un joueur qui j'aime beaucoup de
difficultés à utiliser le mot experts
mais leur efficacité redoutable à courir
autour des tours d'écran s'ajouter en
sortir d'écran c'est un effet des bonnes
coupes au panier aussi moi j'aime
beaucoup sa munition panier
personnellement côté côté capacité
technique n'est fini pratiquement que
d'une ligne mais il trouve toujours une
façon de positionner son pas pour être
capable pour être capable de réussir ou
d'avoir une faute
défensivement parlant ce qui éteint que
les petites choses qui fait qu'ils
donnent des options à ses gardes qui met
un écran qui vont être dégagées sont
songa de la raquette
je suis vraiment qui est qui va trouver
sa place à une bille et je pense qu'on
doit s'attendre à voir
un grand joueur ou une soupe une
superstar mais alors où tu dragues toute
l'europe et moi j'ai un draft jénine une
équipe gagnante de franquin premier tour
une arme supplémentaire à philadelphie 1
baston un miami entre 22 et 30 de ses
biens j'aime les fourchettes précise que
celle-ci
julien est ce que tu le vois enfin de
deux doses parmi cette écurie de gonzaga
c'est que pour toi c'est peut-être le
deuxième meilleur prospect qui n'a pas
beaucoup de prospects cette équipe c'est
pas une question facile c'est pas triste
là bas non gp nous sommes pas là pour
faire dans la facilité monsieur mais il
est clair que la drass avait chargé
cette année donc je sais pas après vous
comme c'était comme celle là ne gagne
plus de 2 mètres et c'est un shooteur
il n'est pas ridicule en défense donc ça
se draft quoi comme un conte à profit
leur demande
alan est ce que toi tu le draft top 20
est ce que tu penses que ça peut être
d'un cadre du salut passe comme elle est
ça serait ça serait incroyable puisque
auto robinson franchement ce qui fait
c'est du grand n'importe quoi en terme
m'adresse mai mais je le drap des 15 je
pense qu'ils pensent des quinze vingts
dix pensent des 15 sus de plus en plus
je trouve que c'est une très très bonne
offre pour l'instant on sait pas on
n'est qu'à 1 - nuit de compétition en
haut mais ça manque de vent autrement
bruit donc je dirais plus sur un joueur
comme ça
tracé au donc ouais je pense des décès
seraient assorties de loterie quoi c'est
c'est étonnant comme la différence entre
l'année dernière c'est adéquat de pour
lui sa position à la draft d'un coup
c'est vous avec un peu près des mêmes
qualités il peut il peut être qu'il
faisait seul kilo de mois l'année
dernière mais sa cote à à monter et
exemple ça que je parlais du contexte
tout à l'heure que tu as très bien
détaillé il ya aussi un côté gonzaga et
hype et que alan le veuille ou non
correct qui se perdent se sort bien
grâce à ça parce qu'il ya de
l'exposition on sait ce qu'on achète en
gros efforts et qu'ils espèrent c'est
d'autant plus vrai là on ne voit en ce
moment avec les juges du joueur qui
entre guillemets surprennent en nba ça
faire plaisir à allan leighton pritchard
ariégeois mais non mais c'est un joueur
qui a fait quatre ans à la fac qu'à
progresser chaque saison et qui est
goguette et reconnue tout le monde le
savait qu'il y avait une éthique de
travail de malade qu'on peut donc et y
réussir en nba donc corps experte là le
chemin est tracé
il suffit d'y aller nous allons passer
pour les deux dernières minutes 2 3
dernières minutes à l'obsession de ben
c'est le retour de la chronique préféré
des français et des francophones
l'obsession de ben ben
hamon
dossier
l' obsession
à la demande générale
les gars du prochain un petit québécois
dans la nba
oui bizarrement si oui qui fait écarter
beaucoup beaucoup de vieux puits qui ont
un profil lège-cap-ferret des lugentz
dorthe et des caillons magny qui sont
qui on est et qui sont présentées à la
drave devant lui bénédicte mathurin qui
joue pour arizona qui de fait au départ
je suppose être un joueur qui allait
qu'allait être là pendant quatre ans
qu'ils allaient se développer mais qui
prend les rênes de l'équipe comme si
c'était un taureau en furie
bénédicte mathurin c'est un énorme poste
de il fait 6 795 il a le shoot le plus
étrange au monde on dirait qu'ils
dansent le twist avec le bois tout cas
c'est un peu le yoyo
on dirait qu'il ya plus grande île adam
ce que j'ai vu ce que c'était festayres
que lui mais plutôt un peu le côté de
son corps pour lui donner un peu d'eux
peu plus de puissance à sentir mes
bénédicte mathurin beaucoup ça lève tôt
non plus mais il est tellement gerrans
pour son pour sa position qui est ça
dérange pas vraiment parce qu'il n'ya
pas de tirer par dessus des gens il
ajoute cette année 4 149% au total 41 %
à 3 points
c'est un joueur physique long emmerdant
affronter et qui est capable de créer
son tig est capable de défoncer tout le
monde s campagne et c'est très très
intrigant de ce côté là sur un gros
défaut par exemple qu'il ya c'est que il
est passeur c'est à dire qu'il est
capable il capable de mettre des
oeillères vraiment très rapidement de
rentrer dans des dents des prises à deux
ça moche et au cercle
bénédicte mathurin garde un oeil dessus
moi j'allais je crois 25e dans mon vécu
ici mais c'est un joueur qui va monter
qui est amené à prendre plus beaucoup
plus grande responsabilité si je m'abuse
lors de sa victoire de leur victoire 2e
over time contre washington state
c'était sa première titularisation et
oppressif arizona denis rappaz à la
march madness si march madness idiap ce
qui se sont auto somptueux et que
maintenant ça à alec j'aimerais qu'on
arrête de mentir deux auditeurs personne
ne vous fait si nous n'avons pas de
régie a aussi je veux laver ma ces
années bas mais fait-il effectivement
c'est ce que je lui dis alors ya
plusieurs petites choses par rapport à
lui déjà si vous voulez le voir c'est
maintenant ce qui fait qu'on va pas voir
risona pendant très longtemps
et derrière derrière il sort en fait de
l'académie elle biella keita qui est à
mexico city allenby et commence à
s'implanter un peu plus gagné ses
jumeaux elle arrive en espagne aussi
très bientôt je crois que ça madrid chez
plus à madrid ou à valence et s'implante
l'un dans l'autre
madrid je crois et il ya un joueur de
gonzaga l'heure actuelle qui est sorti
de la même c'est monsieur oumar ballo
qui est qui est d'origine malienne et
qui est qui est passé par l'espagne qui
est maintenant à qui est passé donc par
la recette l'académie en amérique du sud
est qui et qui aujourd'hui à gonzaga
absolument un mot julien c'est aussi
tazotas zone ça tourne très bien
incroyable alors ouais c'était tu veux
mes yeux comme c'est un gros prospecter
la générale mans moi je m'occupe des
guerres un peu plus sombre mais en fait
j'avais regardé au début de l'année je
vais trouver hyper nerveux mais ça fait
partie de son caractère quoi il avait
l'air assez frustré sur les premiers
matchs alors je sais pas si c'est parce
que il n'avait pas son temps de jeu ou
alors qu'ils aient des stades déjà mais
je l'avais trouvé très un petit peu
énervé quoi sous le terrain un peu comme
haïr williams sais pas si vous avez pas
si vous l'avez vu au début d'année il
était un peu contre les arbitres et la
corvée ouais j'avais trouvé très fins et
son caractère il est explosif 1 c'est un
derby explosif autant dans physiquement
que dans son caractère quoi et là il
ouais ouais ouais
et là il prend comme ati belle qaïda il
a massacré la chine souhaite être quand
il était mal partie dans le match on
sait que c'est une équipe particulière
cam arizona à voir jouer
si jamais trop où ça va ça part dans
tous les sens mais j'ai refais pas non
plus s'il peut s'il peut développer un
désinstalle pas semblé les dictatures il
a le profil rêverie dans le poste 2-3
une blessure qui va finir ses jours à
pas soit 3 mai la pause il a le profil
rêve rien d'un poisson du trou il est
long et les athletics et shooter et si
vous avez la chance où il est très
costaud
si vous avez la chance de l'écouter en
entrevue il ya aussi la voie la plus
sexy de delhaize il sonne comme barry
white
alors tu nous a parlé de tout et de voix
sexy moi ça me fait penser à john y ait
des biens dans ces de plus la version
française de let's twist again
je serai avec ça merci à tous les quatre
vous pouvez retrouver le profit de
bénédicte monture en e pour il a été
opéré qui se perd sur le site
d'envergure point cod scouting me porte
aussi des vidéos sur notre compte
instagram drôle fixé vers la draft de
2021 en or oxydé petite interview à
billy berclau des transferts vous en dit
pas plus jaloux tout moment
m
[Musique]